bonjour j'ai un vestiaire merci de
répondre à nos questions sur la route et
france qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre
selon vous de ce g7 virtuel a
premièrement ça à retourner spa n'y a
pas eu de réunion à g7 depuis biarritz
en septembre 2000 2019
donc il y avait normalement d une
responsabilité de présidence américaine
en 2020 à les atermoiements les
incertitudes du président de l'époque
ont fait que la réunion n'a pas eu lieu
plus effectivement la situation que
vides
donc on est à une réunion maintenant qui
a un vaste agenda entre le co vide la
relance économique et à la situation
donc qu'ils étaient générés par le
ralentissement de l'art et l'invasion de
la pandémie a donc vous avez le dossier
iranien que vous avez évoqué à la
situation bien sûr vis-à-vis de la
russie
donc des dossiers très importants où il
va y avoir à une plus grande cohérence
est beaucoup moins de tension qui avec
les incertitudes représenté par le
précédent gouvernement américain au
cours de l'année 2020 justement angela
merkel salua l'instant je cite un
multilatéralisme renforcée après
l'élection de joe biden comment elle
peut se traduire ce multilatéralisme
selon vous et bien justement parlera à
une situation apaisée
il y avait avec la présidence américaine
précédente toujours des des points
d'interrogation que va-t-il se passer d
incertitude là les positions de chacun
sont des membres du g7 sont claires
présenté à l'avance et il y a une grande
possibilité donc de faire converger ses
points de vue de façon à faire avancer
pratiquement les dossiers qui vont être
traitées a comme vous évoquiez à la
diffusion du vaccin dans les pays qui
sont moins disposés à les recevoir quoi
de moyens financiers l'afrique en
particulier dont il ya et il ya des
possibilités là d' agir rapidement parce
qu'il y à une entente retrouvée alors
justement vous parlez de l'afrique donc
c'est emmanuel macron qui exhorte le
monde à aider l'afrique
washington devrait annoncer quatre
milliards de dollars pour kovacs 1,5
milliard d'euros supplémentaires pour la
lutte mondiale antico vite de la part de
l'allemagne
le monde peut-il vraiment se coordonner
peut-il vraiment parler d'une seule voix
face à la pandémie tco vite 19
alors une seule voix nos pas puisqu'ils
sont 7 n'est ce pas mais en tout cas
avec des voix cohérente et avec un
accord à qu'ils puissent être rapidement
mises en oeuvre parce que dans le cadre
de la pandémie et de la lutte contre la
pandémie
1 le temps est un facteur crucial donc
plus les accords sont concret réel
efficace et bien on les moyens vont être
mis en oeuvre rapidement en particulier
vers l'afrique et aussi sur d'autres
d'autres dossiers
emmanuel macron a qualifié hier
d'insoutenables que les pays pauvres
soit délaissé il a mis en garde contre
une guerre d'influencé autour des
vaccins en citant notamment la chine et
la russie
c'est le retour
de la géopolitique au g7 c'est ça la
géopolitique fait partie du g7 le g7 est
un forum géopolitique donc il n'y a pas
de retour il n'y a pas de naissance il y
à une continuité et effectivement il y a
des intérêts il ya des alliances qui
sont en train de se préparer des spas et
de se renforcer autour d'un grand
dossier par exemple quel dossier chinois
on voit très bien que les pays anglo
saxons à font corps sur les questions de
droits de l'homme de taiwan deux idées
ouigours de hong kong
on voit très bien un rapprochement
insécuritaire militaire entre les pays
asiatiques entre les états unis et et
même l'europe il y à un porte avion
anglais qui va faire escale dans
quelques temps au japon donc il y à des
alliances qui sont en train de se
conforter à sur des dossiers qui sont
mondiaux
justement vous venez d'évoquer le mot
sécuritaire parallèlement au g7
aujourd'hui à la conférence sur la
sécurité de munich sans rendez vous
annuel qui se tient également avec les
principaux dirigeants mondiaux donc
évidemment emmanuel macron joe biden ou
encore angela merkel à quoi est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre là aussi sur cette
réunion même si et du côté de la maison
blanche c'est un petit peu fuité dans
beaucoup d'endroits y compris en europe
et aux états unis je cite l'avancée de
la démocratie est attaqué c'est ce que
devraient donc déclaré tout à l'heure le
président américain sont des extraits de
son discours publiés par la maison
blanche
je cite nous sommes à un moment crucial
gérard vestiaire ça veut dire quoi
ces mots que devrait donc se prononcer
joe biden à ce sommet sur la sécurité en
europe
mais écoutez les semaines et les mois
les années que nous venons de vivre nous
avons vu les démocraties en particulier
la démocratie américaine
attaquer de l'intérieur et nous avons
nous en occident en europe vu aussi des
attaques donc venant de l'extérieur donc
à ces deux situations là où on voit
maintenant être dans une situation
beaucoup plus homogène ou des deux côtés
de l'atlantique il va y avoir une
cohérence et une entente pour faire
front ensemble à ces difficultés
donc on va tourner la page effectivement
des tensions entre washington et
bruxelles
pour faire court et donc on va avoir une
cohérence une une alliance renforcée au
sein de l'otan est elle donc pour faire
face à ces risques extérieurs à 2 de
cyberattaques par exemple qui viennent
de pays divers
merci gérard espère d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste géopolitique et vous êtes
également un chercheur associé à la
fondation pour le moyen-orient